i don't know if you got a chance to see
a
uh a blog post called bitter lesson oh
yes
but rich something that makes an
argument hopefully i can
summarize it perhaps perhaps you can
yeah but
okay so i i mean i can try and you can
correct me which is uh
he makes an argument that it seems if we
look at the long
arc of the history of the artificial
intelligence field
it calls you know 70 years that the
algorithms
from which we've seen the biggest
improvements in practice
are the very simple like dumb algorithms
that are able to leverage
computation and you just wait for the
computation to improve
like all the academics and so on have
fun by finding little tricks and
and congratulate themselves on those
tricks and sometimes those tricks can be
like
big that feel in the moment like big
spikes and breakthroughs but in reality
over the decades it's still the same
dumb algorithm that just
waits for the compute to get faster and
faster do you find
that to be an interesting argument
against the entirety of the field of
machine learning
that's an academic discipline that we're
really just a subfield of computer
architecture yeah
we're just kind of waiting around for
them to do people really don't want to
do hardware work so like that's right i
really don't want to
kind of we're procrastinating yes that's
right just waiting for them to do their
job so that we can pretend to have done
ours so
uh yeah i mean the argument reminds me a
lot of
i think it was a fred gellanek quote uh
early computational linguist who said
you know we're building these
computational linguistic systems and
every time we fire a linguist
performance goes up by ten percent
something like that and so the idea of
us building the knowledge in
in that in that case um was much less he
was finding to be much less successful
than get rid of the people who know
about language as a
you know from a kind of scholastic
academic kind of perspective and replace
them with more compute
and so i think this is kind of a modern
version of that story which is okay we
want to do better
on machine vision you could build in all
these you know
motivated part-based models that you
know that just feel like
obviously the right thing that you have
to have or we can throw a lot of data at
it and guess what we're doing better
with it with a lot of data
so i i hadn't thought about it until
this moment in this way
but what i believe well i've thought
about what i believe
what i believe is that you know
compositionality
and what's the right way to say it the
complexity grows rapidly
as you consider more and more
possibilities like explosively
and so far moore's law has also been
growing explosively
exponentially and so so it really does
seem like well we don't have to
think really hard about the algorithm
design or the way that we build the
systems
because the best benefit we could get is
exponential and the best benefit that we
can get from waiting is exponential
so we can just wait it's got
that's gotta end right and there's hints
now that that moore's law is
is starting to feel some friction uh
starting
the world is pushing back a little bit
um one thing i
don't know do lots of people know this i
didn't know this i was i was trying to
write an essay and yeah moore's law has
been amazing and it's been it's enabled
all sorts of things but there's a
there's also a kind of counter moore's
law which is that the development cost
for each
successive generation of chips also is
doubling
so it's costing twice as much money so
the amount of development money per
cycle or whatever is actually sort of
constant and at some point
we run out of money uh so or we have to
come up with an entirely different way
of of doing the development process so
like i guess i always always a bit
skeptical of the look it's an
exponential curve therefore it has
no end soon the number of people going
to nurips will be greater than the
population of the earth
that means we're going to discover life
on other planets no it doesn't it means
that we're in a
in a sigmoid curve on the front half
which looks a lot like an exponential
the second half is going to look a lot
like diminishing returns
yeah the i mean but the interesting
thing about moore's law if you actually
like look at the technologies involved
it's
hundreds if not thousands of s-curves
stacked on top of each other it's not
actually an exponential curve
it's constant breakthroughs and and
then what becomes useful to think about
which is exactly what you're saying the
cost of development
like the size of teams the amount of
resources that are invested in
continuing to find new s-curves
new breakthroughs and
yeah it's uh it's an interesting idea
you know if we
live in the moment if we sit here today
it seems to be the reasonable thing to
say that
exponentials end and yet in the software
realm
they just keep appearing to be happy
anyway
and it's so i mean it's so
hard to disagree with elon musk on this
because
it like i i've
you know i used to be one of those folks
i'm still one of those folks i've
studied autonomous vehicles that's what
i worked on and
and it's it's like you look what elon
musk is saying about autonomous vehicles
well obviously in a couple years
or in a year or next month we'll have
fully autonomous vehicles like there's
no reason why we can't driving is pretty
simple
like it's just a learning problem and
you just need to convert
uh all the driving that we're doing into
data and just having you all know with
the trains on that data
and uh like we use only our eyes so you
can use cameras and
you can train on it and it's like yeah
that's that what that should work
and then you put that hat on like the
philosophical hat
and but then you put the pragmatic hat
and it's like this is what the flaws of
computer vision are like
this is what it means to trans scale and
then you you put the
human factors the psychology hat on
which is like
it's actually driving us a lot the
cognitive science or cognitive whatever
the heck you call it
is it's really hard it's much harder to
drive than
than we realize there's much larger
number of edge cases
so building up an intuition around this
is uh
around exponential is really difficult
and on top of that
the pandemic is making us think about
exponentials
making us realize that like we don't
understand anything about it we're not
able to intuit exponentials we're either
that's true ultra terrified some part of
the population and some part is like
uh the opposite of whatever the
carefree and we're not managing
blase well wow that's that french
uh it's got an accent so it's uh
it's fascinating to think what what
the limits of this exponential
growth of technology not just moore is
law
it's technology how that
rubs up against the bitter lesson
and gpt-3 and self-play mechanisms
you